[Music]
if i had my if it was if it made sense
yeah i really wish
the draft was right now all we did was
study the draft and that happened in a
few weeks and we just drafted the best
players possible looked at our team and
like oh my gosh we are in trouble here
here and here let's go over paying free
agency and solve that and then it'll be
good the hard thing is you always got to
overpay and free agency yeah so whatever
it is you're going to pay more than
they're worth that's just how it works
right and but what's tough about that
you go do that and then it's two months
later and you're like oh my god this guy
fell to the second round he's so much
better than this free agent but damn we
went that direction two months ago that
doesn't make sense we gotta go this
direction now and that's kind of the
anxiety a little bit about it because it
makes a lot more sense otherwise
49ers coach kyle shanahan with chris
sims that was from the very first
episode of chris sims unbuttoned that
question of doing the draft before free
agency because the nba does its draft
before free agency and others like sean
payton the saints coach i think john
harbaugh the ravens coach has mentioned
from time to time
what it would be like in the nfl and
maybe it would be better to have the
draft before free agency and sharing
just based upon the way kyle shanahan
answered the question
i don't know that the players are going
to want it that way because the players
want teams to have to overspend vaguely
because they don't know what needs
they're going to address in the draft so
they have that greater urgency in march
to spend if you get to do the draft
first
you've identified and you've addressed a
lot of your needs you're less inclined
to go out and make a big splash
financially when the time comes to sign
your free agents
gosh it makes so much sense i mean we
were watching the nba draft yesterday i
was kind of thinking the same thing the
nba does this so early why doesn't the
nfl do this but now everything's so set
in its way in other words the drafts at
a certain time and now they've got tv
and they're making a lot of money off
this thing and the pro days you know
colleges love those things and the
combine now it's going tonight we're
going to make a lot of money off of that
so i don't ever see this thing changing
but it makes so much sense and if you
have the draft earlier you get the
rookies in there earlier and get them in
your program get the playbook in their
hands and you know as kyle shanahan said
you know what you need in free agency
what you didn't address in the draft
instead of coming back in may and june
and going oh my gosh we didn't address
this we've got to try to find this third
and fourth level of free agent to kind
of fill in as we go forward
i think it benefits players generally to
have free agency before the draft but if
the draft comes first it would benefit
players who who happen to be
at the position where maybe there's a
team out there that thought it was going
to address a need in the draft and
failed to do so so would overpay that
specific individual is going to benefit
from being in the right place at the
right time and also one thing that i
would like about draft before free
agency i always get frustrated and i'm
sure the players involved get very
frustrated when there's a quarterback
who signs with a team in march to
ostensibly be the starter and then
that team drafts somebody in round one
or two and that guy's no longer the
starter anymore
i i wouldn't have signed here if i had
known you were gonna draft a quarterback
in round one you flip it around those
veteran quarterbacks know where the
empty seats are they know what they're
getting themselves into when they they
accept that contract
that's a great point mike and we've seen
that a lot over the last couple of years
that veterans sign with those teams
thinking they're going to be there long
term and it turns out that they're a
bridge quarterback in their one year
and i also think that we overthink not
we as but the nfl overthinks
the draft they spend all this time
scouting these players over two years
three years four years however long
they're there they've scouted these
players they know what these players can
do then we go to the combine then we
have pro days then we get into all the
red flags and the concerns and the
wonderlic tests and everything else i
think it takes some of that junk away
and just has you evaluate on what they
did in college what they did in the
combine make them go work out at the
combine let's don't have pro days here's
the combine this is your one opportunity
to work out unless you have a doctor's
note that you're injured let's work out
here and then let's have the draft and
let's go and i think it would make it
much easier on teams than to have to go
through all this garbage time that they
go through in evaluating players to me
it's just much evaluation on players
judge what they did on the field
right i agree with you there the problem
with the combine is unless you're going
to invite 700 players there's always
going to be a guy that's going to do a
pro day workout somewhere because he
didn't get an invitation to the scouting
combine the next thing you know he's
adam thielen so i think that that's part
of the problem part of the challenge
that they would do it but the other
thing and you made this point the nfl
has a perfect off-season schedule now
where it can create revenue
opportunities
big audience
events
with no games being played scouting
combine free agency draft february march
april if you start moving things around
how do you work that calendar and get
the most bang for the buck and i think
that's that's the challenge and so i
think that
the teams may want to do it the media
may like it that way but the league is
going to prefer to keep it the way it is
and i think the players from the
standpoint of the players association
would say we're not changing this we
like having that shotgun approach to
free agency where teams are going to
spend
because they don't know what needs they
ultimately are going to be able to
address in the draft so make them spend
their money before they know what's
behind door number two
yeah i don't ever see this changing even
though a lot of people would like to see
it change just for all those reasons i
think it stays the same and this is the
calendar we have moving forward probably
for eternity in the nfl
we've got over 6 000 votes on the
twitter poll question as to whether
you'd like to see the nfl draft before
free agency so far 55
yes they want the draft and actually
it's ticked up to 56 that's right around
where it's covered one of these things
i've learned about the poll question
the first hundred votes the percentage
generated by those it it's if there's a
hundred thousand votes it's the same
percentage so the sample size doesn't
have to be very big to give us an idea
of where the public stands the public
would like the draft before free agency
i think shereen and i would like it as
well but isn't gonna happen
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports